In the last lecture,
we proved the Cook-Levin theorem
which shows that CNF
satisfiability is MP complete.
We argued directly that arbitrary
MP can return into the satisfiability
problem with efficient reduction.
Of course, it is possible to
make such a direct argument for
every MP complete problem.
But usually this is not necessary.
Once we have one MP complete problem,
we can simply reduce it to
other problems to show that they,
too are MP complete.
In this lesson we use this
strategy to prove that a few more
problems are MP complete.
The goal is to give you a sense
of the breathe of the class of MP
complete problems, and introduce some of
the techniques used in those reductions.